This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Deepa Basti grew up in a very small town in southern India, with mainly books to keep her company. I'm an only child, so there was no one to sort of, you know, fight with and play with at home. And she didn't have many links to the outside world. This was the early 90s before email took off, or AOL chat rooms realized their full, creepy potential. That's producer Vivian Lee. But one day, when she was 10 years old, Deepas father brought her home a children's magazine with potential pen pals listed in the back. Back then, the idea of the penpal was very popular. To have a penpal who lived abroad was
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。迪帕·巴斯蒂在印度南部的一个小镇长大，陪伴她的主要是书。我是独生女，所以家里没有可以吵架或一起玩的人。她与外界的联系也不多。那是90年代初，电子邮件尚未普及，AOL聊天室也还没展现出它们那种令人毛骨悚然的潜力。这是制作人薇薇安·李。但有一天，当她10岁时，迪帕的父亲带回一本儿童杂志，后面列着潜在笔友的名单。那时，笔友的概念非常流行。能有一个住在国外的笔友是
was a big thing. There were pen pals listed from all over the world. Asia, Europe, South America, and Deepa decided to write to two girls living in Russia. But there was a problem. This particular magazine actually came from a second handshop and was completely out of date. The magazines that my dad found for me were from I I think, the early 80s or so, so I would and I found them much later in the 90s, so there was almost a sort of 7 to 8 year gap. But even though 7 years had passed since they listed their addresses in that magazine, these two Russian girls, who were teenagers at this point, actually wrote back. Deepa actually still has a lot of these old letters
是一件大事。名单上有来自世界各地的笔友。亚洲、欧洲、南美洲，迪帕决定给住在俄罗斯的两个女孩写信。但有个问题。这本杂志其实是从二手店买来的，而且完全过时了。我爸爸给我找的杂志大概是80年代初的，而我是在90年代才发现它们的，所以中间有大约7到8年的时间差。但尽管她们在杂志上刊登地址已经过去了7年，这两个当时已经是青少年的俄罗斯女孩竟然回信了。迪帕至今还保留着许多这些旧信件
and read me one from one of her pen pals named Marina. Dear Deepa, how are you? Thanks for your letter and photos. I was glad to see your letter. I have a family, mother, father, and sister. Our town is very small, but I like it. It starts off pretty predictable, but then Marina starts talking about some of her favorite
并为我读了其中一位笔友玛丽娜写的一封信。亲爱的迪帕，你好吗？谢谢你的来信和照片。很高兴收到你的信。我有一个家庭，有妈妈、爸爸和妹妹。我们的城镇很小，但我很喜欢它。开头还挺平淡的，但随后玛丽娜开始谈论她最喜欢的一些
actors. My favorite actors are Shahrukh Khan, Amir Khan, Govinda, Anil Kapoor, Akshay, Karishma Kapoor. They were all Indian. I like India. Indian films, dances, songs, etc. I have the collection photos, actors, songs from Indian films. Deepas Russian pen pals were obsessed with Indian films, more specifically Bollywood. They seem very very interested in Bollywood.
演员。我最喜欢的演员是沙鲁克·汗、阿米尔·汗、戈文达、阿尼尔·卡普尔、阿克谢、卡丽诗玛·卡普尔。他们都是印度人。我喜欢印度。印度电影、舞蹈、歌曲等等。我收藏了印度电影中演员和歌曲的照片。迪帕的俄罗斯笔友对印度电影非常着迷，更具体地说是宝莱坞。她们似乎对宝莱坞非常非常感兴趣。
Bollywood is the Hindi language film industry that comes out of Mumbai, India. It's a portmanteau of Bombay, the former name of Mumbai, where these films are produced, and Hollywood. Bollywood is often conflated with the film industry as a whole, but really, it's just one very flamboyant slice of it. It's usually packed with elaborate song and dance sequences, a fight between good and evil, and a beautiful hero and heroine. There's very little that is left for interpretation, so you know that, okay, there's this guy, there's this girl, they're gonna fall in love and then sort of end up happily ever after.
宝莱坞是源自印度孟买的印地语电影产业。它是孟买（Mumbai，电影制作地的前称Bombay）和好莱坞（Hollywood）的合成词。宝莱坞常被与整个印度电影业混为一谈，但实际上，它只是其中非常华丽的一小部分。它通常包含精心编排的歌舞片段、善与恶的斗争，以及英俊的英雄和美丽的佳人。留给观众解读的空间很少，所以你知道，好吧，有这个男人，有这个女人，他们会坠入爱河，然后从此过上幸福快乐的生活。
And so it's a fairy tale, I think that's the best way to describe it. When she first got these letters, Deepa didn't think much about her penpal's Bollywood fascination. It wasn't until years later that its struck her just how odd it seemed that these girls all the way in Russia knew so much about Shah Rukhan and Neil Kapoor. I don't think a really processed word they meant that somebody sitting so far away in some small town which probably was just like you know the small town I was growing up in way before the internet why were they interested in movies that even be probably weren't watching as much. What Deepa didn't know at the time was that
所以这是一个童话故事，我认为这是最好的描述方式。当迪帕第一次收到这些信时，她并没有太在意笔友对宝莱坞的迷恋。直到多年后，她才意识到，远在俄罗斯的女孩们竟然对沙鲁克·汗和阿尼尔·卡普尔如此了解，这显得多么奇怪。我不认为我当时真正理解她们的意思，为什么远在某个小镇的人——可能和我成长的小镇一样，在互联网出现之前——会对她们自己可能都没怎么看的电影感兴趣。迪帕当时不知道的是
Russian Bollywood fandom wasn't unique to her pen pals childhood experience at all. From the 1950s right up to the collapse of the USSR people in the Soviet Union were completely infatuated with Indian cinema. While the United States was in the grips of Bidlemania, Bollywood Mania was taking over the USSR. There's even a famous story about an Indian actor in the 1960s who was visiting Moscow. He was quietly waiting for a taxi when, out of nowhere, he was swarmed by Russian Bollywood crazed fans.
俄罗斯的宝莱坞粉丝热潮绝非她笔友童年经历的个例。从1950年代一直到苏联解体，苏联人民对印度电影完全着迷。当美国沉浸在“披头士狂热”中时，苏联正被“宝莱坞狂热”所席卷。甚至有一个关于一位印度演员在1960年代访问莫斯科的著名故事。他当时正安静地等出租车，突然间，他被一群疯狂的俄罗斯宝莱坞粉丝包围了。
He jumped into a taxi to escape, but instead of the car racing forward, it started rising up into the air. These fans had lifted the taxi over their heads and carried it down the street. It's possible that story has been embellished over the years, but it speaks to a very real, very intense connection between the two countries. India and the Soviet Union had completely different politics, languages and cultures, but for a brief time, these two nations found they actually had a lot in common and realized this through a love of movies. In the beginnings, in the 20s especially, film started to be very important economically,
他跳进出租车想逃走，但车子没有向前行驶，反而开始升空。这些粉丝把出租车举过头顶，沿着街道抬着走。这个故事可能多年来被夸大了，但它确实反映了这两个国家之间一种非常真实、非常强烈的联系。印度和苏联有着完全不同的政治、语言和文化，但在短暂的时间里，这两个国家发现彼此其实有很多共同点，并通过对电影的热爱意识到了这一点。在初期，特别是在20年代，电影在经济上开始变得非常重要，
together with what brought lots of money to the state. This is Kieryl Razlegov, film critic and historian based in Moscow. He is basically the Russian Leonard Mulden. I am watching about 1000 films per year. And in the early years of cinema, Razlikov says that Soviet directors were at the forefront of filmmaking, not just within the USSR, but in the world.
同时也为国家带来了大量收入。这是基里尔·拉兹洛戈夫，常驻莫斯科的影评人和历史学家。他基本上就是俄罗斯的伦纳德·马尔廷。我每年大约看1000部电影。在电影发展的早期，拉兹洛戈夫说，苏联导演不仅在苏联国内，而且在世界上都处于电影制作的前沿。
Lennon himself said, of all the arts, for us, the cinema is the most important. He believed that a film had the power to reach the masses better than any artist medium and that it could operate as art and propaganda at the same time. But when Stalin came to power, the scales tipped dramatically in favor of propaganda. Everything was controlled even personally by Stalin,
列宁本人曾说，在所有的艺术中，对我们来说，电影是最重要的。他相信电影比任何艺术媒介都更有能力触及大众，并且可以同时作为艺术和宣传工具。但当斯大林掌权后，天平急剧向宣传倾斜。一切都受到控制，甚至由斯大林亲自过问，
so the censorship was very hard. You have the crystallization of a cultural policy that says that all cinema and the arts and literature and everything else needs to follow a set of rules. This is Sudha Rajagopalan, senior lecturer of Eastern European studies at the University of Amsterdam. She says that this set of artistic rules was called Socialist Realism. Socialist realism dictated, in a sense, that all books and films needed to have a standard narrative. Film will show glory of the Politarian struggle. Comrade does heroic acts. All will see the ideal Soviet society and understand the true meaning of communism. Roll credits. Socialist
所以审查非常严厉。你看到了文化政策的结晶，即所有的电影、艺术、文学和其他一切都需要遵循一套规则。这是阿姆斯特丹大学东欧研究高级讲师苏达·拉贾戈帕兰。她说，这套艺术规则被称为“社会主义现实主义”。社会主义现实主义在某种意义上规定，所有的书籍和电影都需要有一个标准的叙事。电影要展示无产阶级斗争的荣耀。同志要做出英雄行为。所有人都要看到理想的苏联社会，并理解共产主义的真正含义。演职员表滚动。社会主义
realism limited artistic creativity, and World War II didn't help. A lot of the factories, a lot of the industries of cinema houses and theaters had to be closed down. Kieril Razlagoff explains that the war caused a shift in the Soviet Union's movie-making priorities. Rather than spending money on making a bunch of movies a year, the Soviet Union wanted to concentrate on just making a handful of well-produced films. Before the war, Razh's Soviet Union made about 70 films per year.
现实主义限制了艺术创造力，而第二次世界大战也没有起到帮助作用。许多工厂、许多电影院和剧院的产业不得不关闭。基里尔·拉兹洛戈夫解释说，战争导致苏联电影制作的重点发生了转移。苏联不再把钱花在每年制作大量电影上，而是想集中精力只制作少数几部高质量的电影。战前，拉兹洛戈夫说苏联每年制作约70部电影。
After the war, it became 5-10 films per year. The idea was to make fewer films, but to make only successful films, which was impossible. The state wanted to focus on quality over quantity, which in some circumstances could be a good thing. But even on its best, imagine if Hollywood was only producing five movies a year, and those movies were Shenler's List, Million Dollar Baby, Sophie's Choice, The Deer Hunter, and 12 Years of Slave. There are masterpieces, but going to the movies would be such a drag. These were hard years for Soviet cinema? So the USSR was producing fewer movies than ever.
战后，变成了每年5到10部。想法是少拍电影，但只拍成功的电影，这根本不可能。国家想把质量置于数量之上，在某些情况下这可能是件好事。但即使在最好的情况下，想象一下如果好莱坞每年只拍五部电影，而这些电影分别是《辛德勒的名单》、《百万美元宝贝》、《苏菲的选择》、《猎鹿人》和《为奴十二年》。这些都是杰作，但去看电影会变得非常沉闷。这对苏联电影来说是艰难的岁月。所以苏联制作的电影比以往任何时候都少。
And the trajectory of Soviet cinema mirrored that of Soviet life, strict censorship and a rejection of anything remotely bourgeois. But by 1953, that would finally begin to change, with the death of Stalin. After the death of Stalin, there were great changes in the film industry. In 1953, Nikita Khrushchev came to power, and he wanted to chart a new course forward for the nation. In 1956, you had this momentous event when Khrushchev gives what is called the secret
苏联电影的轨迹反映了苏联的生活，严格的审查制度和对任何带有资产阶级色彩事物的排斥。但到了1953年，随着斯大林的去世，这种情况终于开始改变。斯大林去世后，电影业发生了巨大的变化。1953年，尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫上台，他想为国家规划一条新的前进道路。1956年，发生了那个重大事件，赫鲁晓夫发表了所谓的秘密
speech. The need was not so secret because it turned out that within a few days everyone knew about it. Khrushchev denounced Stalin's cult of personality and kicked off a period known as the Khrushchev Thaw. Hundreds of thousands of prisoners were released from gulags, political repression subsided, and censorship was relaxed. But Khrushchev also wanted to make ordinary citizens feel more free and happy in their daily lives.
演讲。这其实并不那么秘密，因为几天之内每个人都知道了。赫鲁晓夫谴责了斯大林的个人崇拜，并开启了被称为“赫鲁晓夫解冻”的时期。成千上万的囚犯从古拉格被释放，政治压迫减轻，审查制度也放宽了。但赫鲁晓夫也希望让普通公民在日常生活中感到更自由、更快乐。
Part of this whole desitialization, as it's called in the 1950s, is a kind of shift in the rhetoric about how to address issues of everyday life. And part of this large debate on personal consumption is are people really having a good time. I mean, it really is as simple as that. Are people really having a good time is a simple question that marked an important shift in the government's priorities.
作为1950年代所谓的“去斯大林化”的一部分，关于如何处理日常生活问题的言论发生了一种转变。关于个人消费的这场大辩论的一部分是，人们是否真的过得开心。我的意思是，这真的就这么简单。人们是否真的过得开心，是一个简单的问题，标志着政府优先事项的一个重要转变。
And Krušov decided that one way to ensure that people were having a good time was to get them back in the movie theaters. To also giving people a sense of stability, right? That war is over, that now these are normal times. You can also just go to the movies. You can just hang out with friends. It's also practicality, okay?
赫鲁晓夫决定，确保人们过得开心的一种方法是让他们回到电影院。这也是为了给人们一种稳定感，对吧？战争结束了，现在是正常时期。你也可以去看看电影。你可以和朋友聚聚。这也是出于实用性，对吧？
You need to rebuild your economy. You need to draw people back into the theater. You need to generate revenues. But in order to get people people back into the theater, you need to generate revenues. But in order to get people to go to the movies, the USSR had to increase the amount of films playing in theaters, which required importing more foreign films. America was the biggest movie producer at the time, but this was the middle of the Cold War and a majority of Hollywood films were seen as inappropriately capitalist.
你需要重建经济。你需要把人们吸引回电影院。你需要创造收入。但为了让人们去看电影，苏联必须增加在电影院放映的电影数量，这就需要进口更多的外国电影。美国当时是最大的电影制片国，但这是冷战中期，大多数好莱坞电影被视为不恰当的资本主义产物。
And so the USSR went looking for someone else, a new, fun friend who could entertain millions of fun-starved Soviets without offending their political sensibilities. And it found the perfect candidate in India. It was very important to the Soviet Union to have a friend in India at the time. In 1947, after years of fighting British colonial rule, India became an independent nation. The Soviet Union at the time was looking to build relationships with developing countries, and even though India wouldn't take an official side
于是苏联开始寻找其他人，一个能娱乐数百万渴望娱乐的苏联人，同时又不触犯其政治敏感性的新朋友。它在印度找到了完美的候选人。当时在苏联拥有一个印度朋友非常重要。1947年，经过多年反抗英国殖民统治的斗争，印度成为一个独立国家。当时的苏联正寻求与发展中国家建立关系，尽管印度在冷战期间不会采取官方立场，
during the Cold War, it still looked like a promising choice for friendship. It was a country that had a very strong anti-imperialist politics and political sympathies among its intellectuals. And so both of these things made it actually a very attractive site for the Soviet Union to try out its geopolitics. The idea was that this would be a cultural exchange between the two nations.
但它看起来仍然是一个有前途的友谊选择。这是一个有着非常强烈的反帝政治倾向和知识分子政治同情的国家。因此，这两点使它成为苏联尝试地缘政治的一个非常有吸引力的地点。其想法是，这将是两国之间的文化交流。
The Soviet Union would import Indian films and India would import the same number of Soviet films. They would become cinematic pen pals. In 1954, the Soviet Union took a big step towards the artistic partnership by hosting an Indian film festival in Moscow. It was a very huge event in the beginning of the 50s because the Indian films came to Russia. This is Kieril Radlegov again. Radlegov was just a kid in 1954, but he still remembers this festival because it was the debut of a Hollywood film called Avada,
苏联将进口印度电影，印度也将进口同样数量的苏联电影。他们将成为电影笔友。1954年，苏联通过在莫斯科举办印度电影节，向这种艺术伙伴关系迈出了重要的一步。这是50年代初的一件大事，因为印度电影来到了俄罗斯。这是基里尔·拉兹洛戈夫。拉兹洛戈夫在1954年还是个孩子，但他仍然记得这个电影节，因为这是一部名为《流浪者》的印度电影的首映，
which translates to the Vagabond. Avada. Avada. Avada. Avada centers around a Charlie Chaplinous tramp character who's forced into a life of crime, but true love makes him see the error of his ways. It's full of sentimental music, lessons in morality, a lot of deep longing stairs, and some troubling misogyny. Was the biggest ever commercial success in Soviet Union in that period? Avara was literally the number one movie in 1954 in the USSR selling over 63 million tickets. To put that into perspective, the top-grossing movie of 2017, Star Wars The Last Jedi, sold 57 million tickets in the US.
翻译过来就是《流浪者》。《流浪者》。《流浪者》。《流浪者》围绕着一个查理·卓别林式的流浪汉角色展开，他被迫走上犯罪道路，但真爱让他看到了自己的错误。它充满了感伤的音乐、道德教训、许多深情的凝视和一些令人不安的厌女症。这是当时苏联商业上最成功的电影吗？《流浪者》确实是1954年苏联票房第一的电影，售出了超过6300万张票。为了对比一下，2017年票房最高的电影《星球大战：最后的绝地武士》在美国售出了5700万张票。
This is Anton Seidouzoff. He grew up in Uzbekistan when it was still a part of the USSR, and he remembers just how huge Avada and other Indian films were for Soviet audiences. After that first film festival in Moscow, the film star Raj Kapoor quickly became a mega celebrity throughout the Soviet Union. Truck drivers had a photo of Raj Kapoor on their windshields next to Stalin.
这是安东·塞杜佐夫。他在乌兹别克斯坦长大，当时那里还是苏联的一部分，他记得《流浪者》和其他印度电影对苏联观众来说有多么巨大。在莫斯科那次电影节之后，电影明星拉杰·卡普尔迅速成为整个苏联的超级巨星。卡车司机在挡风玻璃上把拉杰·卡普尔的照片和斯大林的照片放在一起。
That Indian actor that we mentioned earlier, the one who was mobbed by Russian fans and was hoisted into the air in a taxi, that was Raj Kapoor. They were so excited to see him that they apparently lifted his taxi and carried it over their heads. I mean, it sounds incredible, but yeah, such was his popularity in the USSR. Raj Kapoor became kind of a cultural ambassador between the two countries. When he visited Moscow in 1956, he spoke about the ways in which movies could bring their countries closer together, and even quoted Lenin's original feelings of what cinema could accomplish.
我们之前提到的那位印度演员，那位被俄罗斯粉丝围攻并被抬进出租车的演员，就是拉杰·卡普尔。他们太兴奋了，以至于他们竟然把他的出租车抬起来，举过头顶。我的意思是，这听起来不可思议，但确实，他在苏联就是这么受欢迎。拉杰·卡普尔成为了两国之间的文化大使。当他在1956年访问莫斯科时，他谈到了电影如何能拉近两国距离，甚至引用了列宁关于电影能实现什么的最初感受。
And that cinema is the greatest weapon to mold your country and to bring about different countries into one. of what cinema could accomplish. And if the peak of their Bollywood craze, Soviet movie theaters were constantly showing Indian films. So there will be 20 movie theaters operating from 10 a.m. to 10 p.m. to hours a day and yeah, good half of them will be playing Indian movies. And even the music from these films became popular. Maybe a little too popular. Neighbors in the apartment complex at my family lived at were playing Indian songs on their vinyls from 6 a.m. to practically midnight.
电影是塑造国家并将不同国家团结在一起的最伟大的武器。在宝莱坞热潮的巅峰时期，苏联电影院不断放映印度电影。会有20家电影院从早上10点营业到晚上10点，每天24小时，是的，其中有一半在放映印度电影。甚至这些电影里的音乐也变得流行起来。也许太流行了。我家人住的公寓楼里的邻居从早上6点到几乎午夜都在用唱片机播放印度歌曲。
Sometimes the same song or over and over again. The USSR's intense love of Indian cinema sometimes even seeped into the content of Bollywood films. Deepa told me about a Raj Kapoor movie from 1955 called Tree 420, in which the main character nods to the close relationship with the Soviet Union in one of the songs. This is very old and very popular song called Meera Juta Hejapani.
有时同一首歌反复播放。苏联对印度电影的强烈热爱有时甚至渗透到了宝莱坞电影的内容中。迪帕告诉我一部1955年的拉杰·卡普尔电影《诈骗者》，主角在其中一首歌中向与苏联的亲密关系致意。这是一首非常古老且非常流行的歌，叫《我的鞋子是日本造的》。
Can you please sing it for me? Why I can't? I mean, I'm not a singer. I know one other show with a singer. Okay. Okay, this is going to sound really bad. Um, Mirajuta hejapani, Patluun Englishtanis, Sarpelato, Viresi, Pervidel, Hejostani, Mirajuta hejapani, Patluun Englishtanis, Sarpelato, Virusi, Pervidel, Hejostani. The lyrics in Hindi translate too are shoes are from Japan, my trousers are from England.
你能为我唱一下吗？我为什么不能？我的意思是，我不是歌手。我知道另一首。好吧。好吧，这听起来会很糟糕。嗯，我的鞋子是日本造的，裤子是英国造的，头上的帽子是俄罗斯造的，但我的心是印度人。我的鞋子是日本造的，裤子是英国造的，头上的帽子是俄罗斯造的，但我的心是印度人。印地语歌词翻译过来是：我的鞋子是日本造的，我的裤子是英国造的。
But most importantly, there's a lyric that says, the hat on top of my head is from Russia. It's very curious that there is this Laltopiru scene or the red hat, obviously a communist reference, knowing that they have a very wide Russian audience and that it's always good marketing strategy to include them in the you know in the solv It's hard to say exactly why Bollywood became such a phenomenon in the Soviet Union But part of the reason is that they offered something you simply couldn't find in Soviet films. You do not see the kind of unbridled personal emotion that you see in Indian cinema, you know, where it's, I mean, those who don't like it say it's over the top, right? Here's
但最重要的是，有一句歌词说，我头上的帽子是俄罗斯造的。非常好奇，这里有这个“红帽子”场景，显然是一个共产主义的指涉，知道他们有非常广泛的俄罗斯观众，而且把他们包含在内总是一个很好的营销策略。很难说为什么宝莱坞在苏联会成为一种现象，但部分原因是它们提供了你在苏联电影中根本找不到的东西。你不会看到你在印度电影中看到的那种肆无忌惮的个人情感，你知道，那些不喜欢它的人说它太夸张了，对吧？这是
Surah Rajagopalan again. So it's in a sense where you have a man and a woman and they fall in love and then you have four songs that are only about falling in love, right? And then you have dance sequences shot out in the nature and then you have a rainfall that falls and they drenched and they're in love and they're exultant and there is this, there is an unbridled sense to Indian cinema, right? A sense that there are no boundaries to what you can feel and how you can express those feelings.
苏达·拉贾戈帕兰。所以这在某种意义上是，一个男人和一个女人坠入爱河，然后你有四首歌专门讲坠入爱河，对吧？然后你有在大自然中拍摄的舞蹈片段，然后有降雨，他们被淋湿了，他们相爱了，他们欣喜若狂，有一种肆无忌惮的感觉，对吧？一种感觉，即你的感受以及你如何表达这些感受是没有界限的。
But it wasn't just that Bollywood felt exotic and different. The exuberant sentimentality was certainly unfamiliar, but there was also something deeply relatable at the core of Indian cinema. Indian and Soviet films were both often about self-sacrifice, a world divided into good versus evil and class struggle, but Rajagopalan conducted a number of interviews of Indian film fans in the former Soviet Union, and a lot of them pointed to something that we don't quite have a word for in English. So, a lot of Russians would say to me we used to watch Indian movies, and are Dusha's
但这不仅仅是因为宝莱坞感觉异国情调和与众不同。那种奔放的感伤主义当然是不熟悉的，但印度电影的核心也有一些非常容易引起共鸣的东西。印度和苏联电影通常都关于自我牺牲、一个分为善与恶的世界以及阶级斗争，但拉贾戈帕兰在前苏联采访了许多印度电影迷，他们中的许多人指出了一个我们在英语中找不到对应词汇的东西。所以，很多俄罗斯人会对我讲，我们过去常看印度电影，因为我们的“杜莎”
they matched. And Dusha is the Russian word for soul. The soul she's talking about isn't an individual soul. Instead, Dusha is kind of a national essence, or a collective identity. So the Dusha, that's the Russians like to talk about their soul is one that endures. It has been through hard histories, but it endures, it's resilient, it's kind of spiritual in that sense of not being attached to material pursuits. And so this Dusha, they believed, was one that they shared with Indians.
是契合的。“杜莎”是俄语中“灵魂”的意思。她所说的灵魂不是个人的灵魂。相反，“杜莎”是一种民族本质或集体认同。所以，俄罗斯人喜欢谈论的这种“杜莎”，是那种能够忍受的灵魂。它经历过艰难的历史，但它能够忍受，它是有韧性的，在某种意义上是精神性的，不依附于物质追求。所以他们相信，这种“杜莎”是他们与印度人共享的。
and so this dusha, they believed, was one that they shared with Indians. Bollywood films played on theater screens in the USSR right up into the later years of the Soviet Union. Towards the 1980 new era of DHS, and that's exactly when Arnold and Stalone they completely removed Raj Kapoor another Indian actress from the screens of ordinary Soviet audience. In the final years of the USSR, rather than watching Shree 420 or Zita Engita, a lot of people preferred watching bootleg videos of Conan the Barbarian in Rambo. And when the Soviet Union collapsed,
所以他们相信，这种“杜莎”是他们与印度人共享的。宝莱坞电影在苏联的电影院屏幕上一直放映到苏联的晚期。到了1980年代，随着录像带的新时代到来，阿诺德·施瓦辛格和史泰龙完全把拉杰·卡普尔和其他印度演员从普通苏联观众的屏幕上挤走了。在苏联的最后几年，比起看《诈骗者》或《吉塔和西塔》，很多人更喜欢看《野蛮人柯南》和《第一滴血》的盗版录像带。当苏联解体时，
American film and television quickly flooded the market. But Bollywood isn't totally gone. There's still a channel on Russian TV that broadcasts Indian films and television 24 hours a day. And if you ever do karaoke in Uzbekistan, you might just hear an old man singing songs from Avada. Avada. Avada.
美国电影和电视迅速涌入市场。但宝莱坞并没有完全消失。俄罗斯电视台仍然有一个频道，24小时播放印度电影和电视。如果你在乌兹别克斯坦唱卡拉OK，你可能会听到一位老人唱《流浪者》里的歌。《流浪者》。《流浪者》。
Avada. Avada. Avada. Avada. Okay, so that's the first half of the story. But this was a one-to-one exchange, right? So now we gotta talk about all the Soviet films that were popular in India and how Deepa Boss they grew up with posters of Soviet film stars in her bedroom.
《流浪者》。《流浪者》。《流浪者》。《流浪者》。好吧，这是故事的前半部分。但这是一种一对一的交流，对吧？所以现在我们得谈谈在印度流行的所有苏联电影，以及迪帕·巴斯蒂是如何在卧室里贴着苏联电影明星的海报长大的。
Not so much. We never watched any Russian film in India, you know, in those, in those years. Oh, that's awkward. Unlike Indian films which were widely beloved in all parts of the USSR, Soviet films were just not popular in India. Indian movie theaters weren't great at distributing Soviet movies and when they did, they often screened them late at night when no one would even want to go see a movie. And these were, you know, these were very serious and somber films.
并没有。我们在印度从来没看过任何俄罗斯电影，你知道，在那些年里。哦，那很尴尬。与在苏联各地广受欢迎的印度电影不同，苏联电影在印度并不受欢迎。印度电影院在发行苏联电影方面做得并不好，即使发行了，也经常在深夜放映，那时根本没人想去看电影。而且这些电影，你知道，是非常严肃和沉闷的电影。
I mean, you know, you watch them at 11 at night, you know? I mean, it's not the best hours. Seriously, you tried watching Tarkovsky's stalker at 11 p.m. and staying conscious. I tried, I failed, I never looked back. They bought a far more from us. They distributed them much better than we ever did theirs. And our films were much more popular popular than their films were in India.
我的意思是，你知道，你在晚上11点看它们，你知道？我的意思是，这不是最好的时间。说真的，你试过在晚上11点看塔可夫斯基的《潜行者》并保持清醒吗？我试过，我失败了，我再也没看过。他们从我们这里买的更多。他们发行得比我们发行他们的电影好得多。而且我们的电影比他们的电影在印度受欢迎得多。
That was the reality. Soviet films just didn't have the same mainstream appeal as Indian films did. Of course, there were surely Indian film nerds with thick framed glasses who could appreciate Russian art house cinema. But on the whole, people in India just weren't as drawn to socialist realism.
这就是现实。苏联电影在印度并没有像印度电影那样的主流吸引力。当然，肯定有戴着厚框眼镜的印度电影书呆子能欣赏俄罗斯艺术电影。但总的来说，印度人对社会主义现实主义并不那么感兴趣。
But even though Soviet film never really took off in India, the goal of a two-way cultural exchange wasn't a total failure. It just took another form. Here's Deepa Basti again. Soviet books were flooded into the country in all languages. The USSR made Soviet literature widely available all over India. Beautiful, hard-bound Russian classics were translated into multiple Indian languages and available at incredibly low prices. There were several generations of Indians who grew up on these books. So we had everything from Tolstoy, Pushkin, Dostoyevsky, all the greats of Russian literature,
但尽管苏联电影在印度从未真正流行起来，双向文化交流的目标并非完全失败。它只是采取了另一种形式。这是迪帕·巴斯蒂。苏联书籍大量涌入印度，涵盖各种语言。苏联使苏联文学在印度各地广泛传播。精美的硬壳俄罗斯经典名著被翻译成多种印度语言，并以极低的价格出售。有几代印度人是读着这些书长大的。所以我们拥有从托尔斯泰、普希金、陀思妥耶夫斯基到所有俄罗斯文学巨匠的作品，
to children's books, to science and technology, textbooks. Deep it told me there wasn't even a bookstore in our town, but her bookshelf at home was filled with great works from Russian authors. In fact, I think I was about 10 or 11 when I picked up Maxim Gorkey's mother that I remember was my first big adult novel and it was for me it was fascinating because it was like a big book it was fat and it was hard bound. She went on to read Pushkin selected works in Dostoyevsky's The Idiot all before the age of 17. Deepa grew up and became a writer, and she believes she owes a lot to growing up surrounded by Russian literature.
还有儿童读物、科学和技术教科书。迪帕告诉我，她镇上甚至没有一家书店，但她家里的书架上摆满了俄罗斯作家的伟大作品。事实上，我想我大约10或11岁时拿起了马克西姆·高尔基的《母亲》，我记得那是我的第一本大型成人小说，对我来说它很迷人，因为它是一本大书，又厚又硬壳。她在17岁之前还读了普希金选集和陀思妥耶夫斯基的《白痴》。迪帕长大后成为了一名作家，她认为这很大程度上归功于她在俄罗斯文学的包围中长大。
Obviously, you know, reading these books at that age definitely influenced the way I read now, the way I think now, the way I write now, because I read them at a very formative age and I still have a deep connection to to these books. As I was talking with Deepa, I kept thinking about the intention of this whole cultural exchange to influence. So I asked her if she thought at all about the fact that those books were part of some larger geopolitical propaganda scheme. Yes, I do think about this whole propaganda side of it, but for me it was, you know, literature for itself to be enjoyed because it is great writing. I don't think anyone's going to remember a politician's speech, but you
显然，你知道，在那个年纪读这些书绝对影响了我现在的阅读方式、思考方式和写作方式，因为我在一个非常具有塑造性的年纪读了它们，而且我至今与这些书有着深厚的联系。当我和迪帕交谈时，我一直在思考这种文化交流旨在产生影响的意图。所以我问她，是否考虑过这些书是某种更大地缘政治宣传计划的一部分。是的，我确实考虑过整个宣传方面，但对我来说，你知道，文学本身就是为了享受，因为它是伟大的写作。我不认为有人会记得政客的演讲，但你
talk about books or you talk about cinema or you talk about music and that stays with you possibly for the rest of your life. And how exactly did the Soviets watch all those American movies that flooded into the Soviet Union at a time when not that many people had a VCR? Well they watched them on the movie bus. Vivian tells me that story after this. So I'm back in the studio with Vivian Lee, who produced and reported that story. And there was actually a little piece of this story
谈论书籍、电影或音乐，这些会伴随你，可能伴随你余生。那么苏联人究竟是如何在那个没多少人有录像机的时代观看所有那些涌入苏联的美国电影的呢？嗯，他们在电影巴士上观看。薇薇安在之后会告诉我那个故事。所以我回到了演播室，和制作并报道那个故事的薇薇安·李在一起。其实这个故事里有一小部分
that actually got you started that didn't fit in the story that we're gonna talk about now. Yes, that is very exciting for me. So yeah, a while back I stumbled on across this article in the Atlantic by someone named Elmar Hashmoth. So Elmar is an English professor at Biola University now, but he was born in a city called Baku in the Azerbaijan's Soviet Socialist Republic, and he grew up watching a lot of movies
让你开始了这段报道，但没放进故事里，我们现在来谈谈。是的，这对我来说非常令人兴奋。所以，前段时间我在《大西洋月刊》上偶然发现了埃尔马·哈什莫特写的一篇文章。埃尔马现在是拜欧拉大学的英语教授，但他出生在阿塞拜疆苏维埃社会主义共和国的一个叫巴库的城市，他从小看了很多电影
in the Soviet Union. And so, obviously, this was before the fall of the USSR, so before 1991. Yes, he was born in 1979, and he said that the 80s were kind of an odd time to be a young person and a movie buff in the USSR because it was pretty close to the collapse of the USSR and that tension and anxiety tended to seep into Soviet media. The 80s were kind of a dark and cynical time and I think that was reflected in the films and shows that were made. A lot of it was just sort of dark and critical and hopeless.
在苏联。所以，显然，这是在苏联解体之前，也就是1991年之前。是的，他出生于1979年，他说80年代在苏联做一个年轻人和电影迷是一段奇怪的时光，因为那时离苏联解体很近，那种紧张和焦虑往往会渗透到苏联媒体中。80年代是一个黑暗和愤世嫉俗的时代，我认为这反映在当时制作的电影和节目中。很多内容只是黑暗、批判和绝望。
This sounds like a lot of the sentiment that we talk about is making people turn to Bollywood's and I'm like, have some hope and something like that. Is that what he did? Yes, so he did grow up watching a lot of Bollywood films. He told me that his first crush was Hemamolini from Zita and Gita, but he actually watched a lot of Hollywood movies too. So a few American films did make it into the Soviet Union? Yes.
这听起来很像我们谈论的让人们转向宝莱坞的那种情绪，我想说，带点希望之类的。他是那样做的吗？是的，他确实从小看了很多宝莱坞电影。他告诉我，他的初恋是《吉塔和西塔》里的赫玛·马连尼，但他其实也看了很多好莱坞电影。所以确实有一些美国电影进入了苏联？是的。
So the Soviet Union, like they did still import American films during the Cold War. They were just very selective of what they would screen and films were heavily censored or edited. And Elmer told me about this kind of funny example of a classic film that they used to play. The one I always think about is some like it hot with Marilyn Monroe. But in the Soviet Union, it was actually translated
所以苏联，他们确实在冷战期间进口美国电影。他们只是对放映什么非常挑剔，而且电影受到严格审查或剪辑。埃尔马告诉我一个关于他们过去常放映的一部经典电影的有趣例子。我总是想到玛丽莲·梦露主演的《热情如火》。但在苏联，它实际上被翻译成
Girls Only and Jazz. I don't know what that's better. It sounds provocative. It really does. Yeah what that's better. It sounds provided. It really does. Yeah. That's weird. Yeah, and he told me that scenes were often cut or edited out or just translated completely differently to change the context.
《只有女孩和爵士乐》。我不知道这是否更好。听起来很挑衅。确实如此。是的，这很奇怪。是的，他告诉我场景经常被剪掉或编辑，或者翻译得完全不同以改变语境。
A lot of the more spicy language was also cleaned up and there were some scenes that were completely cut or translated differently. But towards the end of the 70s, bootleg movies were a lot easier to get a hold of because of the VCR player. And so this is how a lot of people like LMR first watch uncensored American. That's what I was just talking about here. The way you save VCR player is if you are of an agent
很多更辛辣的语言也被清理了，有些场景被完全剪掉或翻译得不同。但到了70年代末，由于录像机的出现，盗版电影更容易获得了。所以这就是像埃尔马这样的人第一次观看未删减美国电影的方式。这就是我刚才在这里谈论的。你保存录像机的方式是如果你是那个年龄段的人
which you've never touched when. I grew up with those really thick plastic VHSs. a whole I had a whole collection. So you should just say VCR. Okay. Okay. So he had a VCR. Okay good. Not a VCR player. Yeah so like this is how he first watched uncensored American films. Like you told me the first action film he saw was first blood the original Rambo movie. Yes, and it's kind of funny. Like it wasn't even that these movies were exciting because they were illegal. But compared to Soviet films, American films just offered a lot of stimulation.
你从来没碰过。我是在那些厚厚的塑料VHS录像带中长大的。我有一整套收藏。所以你应该只说录像机。好吧。好吧。所以他有一台录像机。好吧，很好。不是录像机播放器。是的，所以这就是他第一次观看未删减美国电影的方式。就像你告诉我的，他看的第一部动作片是《第一滴血》，原版兰博电影。是的，这很有趣。这些电影之所以令人兴奋，甚至不是因为它们是非法的。但与苏联电影相比，美国电影确实提供了很多刺激。
It was kind of like a barrage on the senses. I just remember the violence, the blood and sweat and machine guns and yeah, like Sylvester Stallone's bulging muscles. Yeah, those films were not known for their subtlety. No, they're pretty intense. Yeah. But yeah, so at least in Baku where El Mars from, people got pretty creative with how they screen these movies
这就像是对感官的轰炸。我只记得暴力、鲜血、汗水、机关枪，还有西尔维斯特·史泰龙隆起的肌肉。是的，那些电影并不以微妙著称。不，它们非常激烈。是的。但至少在埃尔马所在的巴库，人们在放映这些电影时变得非常有创意，
because they were still legal at this point. So he actually grew up watching bootleg Hollywood films in video vans. Oh, so tell me how that works. Yeah, so in certain parts of the Soviet Union, like from probably like the 70s to about the 90s, there is this popular form of transportation called the Mushrutka. It's sort of like a cross between a taxi cab and a bus and they were these Latvian-made mini buses that were called it was like the Roth series and so people refer to them as Rafics. So during the days these were just public transit
因为当时它们仍然是合法的。所以他其实是在视频面包车里看着盗版好莱坞电影长大的。哦，告诉我那是怎么运作的。是的，在苏联的某些地方，大概从70年代到90年代，有一种流行的交通工具叫“小巴”。它有点像出租车和公共汽车的结合体，它们是拉脱维亚制造的小型巴士，被称为“拉夫”系列，所以人们称它们为“拉夫车”。白天这些是公共交通工具，
but at night some of these Roth drivers would convert their buses into mini mobile movie theaters. And so did they have like TVs and VCRs or screens? Like how did it work? Yes, exactly. So at this time, it wasn't really super common for people to own their own VCRs and their homes. So this made it just a lot easier to bring movies to larger groups of people to watch together.
但到了晚上，一些拉夫车司机把他们的巴士改造成移动迷你电影院。他们有电视、录像机或屏幕吗？它是怎么运作的？是的，完全正确。当时，人们在家里拥有自己的录像机并不常见。所以这使得把电影带给更多人一起观看变得容易多了。
And so were these planned? Was he like, like, were they like ice cream trucks? Were they just would show up? Yes, that is actually exactly what it was like it was it was bored of mouth and there's like no official schedule I compare it to like an ice cream van or it just showed up and people will be like the video van is here And well the kids from from the yard were just run over and and watch a movie did they get inside the van and watch a movie? Yes, yes, so I guess it's kind of like a like a grittier version of watch a movie. Did they get inside the van and watch a movie? Yes, yes. So I guess it's kind of like a grittier version
这些是有计划的吗？就像冰淇淋车一样？它们只是会出现吗？是的，其实就是那样，它是口口相传的，没有官方时间表，我把它比作冰淇淋车，它只是出现，人们会说“视频车来了”，然后院子里的孩子们就会跑过去看电影。他们进车里看电影吗？是的，是的，所以我猜这有点像看电影的粗犷版。他们进车里看电影吗？是的，是的。所以我猜这有点像
of watching a movie on one of those entertainment systems in a family mini van. So the television and the VCR would be in the front of the van right behind the bus driver's seat. And there'd be curtains on the windows to block out light and make it a little bit more discreet from the outside. We all sat like you would sit in the bus facing forward and one of my vivid memories is that it always smelled like stale cigarette smoke because people smoked probably in there all day.
在家庭小型货车里的娱乐系统上看电影的粗犷版。电视和录像机会放在面包车的前部，就在司机座位后面。窗户上会有窗帘来遮挡光线，使外面看起来更隐蔽。我们都像坐在公共汽车上一样朝前坐，我记忆深刻的一点是，那里总是有一股陈旧的香烟味，因为人们可能整天都在里面抽烟。
Sometimes people would actually be smoking while we watched a movie. There's a little 10-year-old sitting next to someone to change smoking the bus. Oh my god, so weird. But something that I thought was interesting was the way that these films were translated. So it was really common that the people who dubbed these movies into Russian, like he speaks Azerbaijani, but he also speaks Russian too.
有时人们在看电影时真的会抽烟。一个10岁的小孩坐在一个在车里抽烟的人旁边。天哪，太奇怪了。但我认为有趣的一点是这些电影的翻译方式。所以，给这些电影配音成俄语的人非常普遍，他会说阿塞拜疆语，但他也会说俄语。
And so a lot of these movies were screened in Russian by translators or journalists or film critics by day. And at night, they would illegally translate Hollywood Hollywood movies and usually it was directly over the original soundtrack usually guy and usually in one take. So they just doubt right over it. Right over. They even remove the old dialogue. They didn't I don't even think they lowered the dialogue. I actually have a clip here for you to hear what it sounds like. So this is a clip from the movie The Thing. And here, this was something.
所以很多电影是由翻译、记者或影评人在白天用俄语放映的。到了晚上，他们会非法翻译好莱坞电影，通常是直接在原声带上翻译，通常是一个人，通常是一次录完。所以他们直接盖过它。直接盖过。他们甚至移除了旧的对话。我甚至不认为他们调低了对话音量。我这里有一个片段让你听听听起来是什么样的。这是电影《怪形》的一个片段。在这里，这是某样东西。
I don't know what the hell's in there. I don't know what's in there. To have something terrible, Bening's, to be honest. What's this? What's happening? Hey, palmer, what's this? I know where the hell it is. Child.
我不知道那里面是什么鬼东西。我不知道那里面是什么。有什么可怕的东西，老实说。这是什么？发生了什么？嘿，帕尔默，这是什么？我知道它在哪儿。孩子。
That's what the flame trover is. Mac will never leave. What do you mean? Agnemyot, shivelis. He's not really selling that. I know that. I know that. I know that. I know that. He's not really selling it. No, he's not going to win any best acting awards for this. What a strange introduction to American culture. Yeah, I can't imagine. You must think that America is the weirdest place in the world.
这就是火焰喷射器。麦克永远不会离开。你什么意思？火焰喷射器，动起来。他演得真不怎么样。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。他演得真不怎么样。不，他不会因为这个获得任何最佳表演奖。多么奇怪的美国文化介绍。是的，我无法想象。你一定会认为美国是世界上最奇怪的地方。
You're just seeing all these movies. But Elmar said did say something kind of funny, which is that because of the way these films were dubbed over, with you being able to hear both English and Russian at the same time, he has a theory that it made him better at acquiring new languages. I speculate that that's how I got so good at English. We were constantly hearing a direct translation of what we were hearing in the
你只是在看所有这些电影。但埃尔马确实说了一件有趣的事，那就是因为这些电影的配音方式，让你能同时听到英语和俄语，他有一个理论，认为这让他更擅长学习新语言。我推测这就是我英语变得这么好的原因。我们一直在听到我们所听到的原始英语的直接翻译。
original English. I mean, he came here in 2006. Oh goodness. And his English is almost perfect. Like, I barely detect any kind of accent. And this is based on his own wild speculation because a lot of people grow watching these movies, but his English is very good. There's actually a great documentary
我的意思是，他是2006年来到这里的。哦，天哪。他的英语几乎完美。我的意思是，我几乎察觉不到任何口音。这是基于他自己的疯狂推测，因为很多人看着这些电影长大，但他的英语非常好。其实有一部很棒的纪录片
called Chuck Norris versus communism about the Romanian woman named Irina Nistor, who single-handedly dubbed like 3,000 Western movies into Romania during those times. So if you're interested in watching that. Oh, wow, that's so cool. If people want to read Omar's original story, we'll link to it on the website.
叫《查克·诺里斯大战共产主义》，讲述了一位名叫伊琳娜·尼斯特的罗马尼亚女性，她在那个时代独自为3000部西方电影配音。如果你有兴趣看的话。哦，哇，太酷了。如果人们想读埃尔马的原始故事，我们会在网站上提供链接。
Yes, that will be on the website. That's so good. Oh, this would a great little detail about the story. Cool, thanks so much. Thank you. 99% invisible was produced This Week By Vivian Lee Mixing Tech Production By Sheree Fusif Music By Sean Rial
是的，那会在网站上。太棒了。哦，这是关于这个故事的一个很棒的细节。酷，太感谢了。谢谢。本周的《99%隐形》由薇薇安·李制作，混音技术制作由谢丽·福西夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。
Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstade, is the digital director. The rest of the team is Avery Trollman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald Delaney Hall, Taren Mazza, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Jessica Bachman at the University of Washington. She organized an oral history project called Bollywood and Bolsheviks, Indo-Soviet Collaboration in Literature and Film, and to Deepa Basti. You can find out more about Bollywood and Bolsheviks as well as find some of Deepa's writing on our website.
Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colstade是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Avery Trollman、Joe Rosenberg、Emmett Fitzgerald、Delaney Hall、Taren Mazza、Sophia Klatsker以及我Roman Mars。特别感谢华盛顿大学的Jessica Bachman。她组织了一个名为“宝莱坞与布尔什维克：印苏文学与电影合作”的口述历史项目，还要感谢Deepa Basti。你可以在我们的网站上了解更多关于“宝莱坞与布尔什维克”的信息，并找到Deepa的一些文章。
99% Invisible is Project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Work. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our true home on the web is 99PI.org. Radio tilp you. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99% Invisible是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到所有这些节目。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIWork。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们在网络上真正的家是99PI.org。RadioTopia，来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。